Audra from The Bold and area command
were dispatched for a report of a
shooting inside of her residence located
at the 200 block of Kipling Street
as officers arrived they quickly set up
containment on the residents they were
then quickly contacted by several people
identifying themselves to be related to
the residents those people advise the
officers they received a phone call from
another person stating there's a
shooting in the house and someone was
shot I was just quickly formed an arrest
team went into the residence as they
went into the residence they located a
Hispanic male in his 40s who were
suffering from a gunshot wound medical
has quickly summoned to the scene after
they arrived they pronounced the male
deceased here on scene based on those
details homicide investigators have
arrived and they have taken over this
investigation right now the information
I have is extremely preliminary at this
point the information we know is that
prior to the incident the people who
normally live at this house were in the
process of preparing the house to be
sold they had several workers who were
appear to be family related who are at
the residence conducting work on the
house as they're preparing it
while that work was being going on a
family member received a call from one
of them stating that there was a
shooting and that the mail was shot in
the house and then that's what
precipitated the call to the Las Vegas
Metro Police Department and then that's
when we found the male shot inside the
residence right now those are the
details that I have right now right now
we are interviewing all the witnesses
that were either contacted by phone or
anybody in the area who might have heard
anything we are also canvassing the area
for any additional Witnesses or any
cameras that might have identified
anything that occurred at the residence
I urge anyone with any information
related to this investigation to please
contact Las Vegas homicide section or
reach out to Crime Stoppers of Nevada
the information will remain anonymous
right now from a Transit perspective the
only street that is shut down is Bromley
right now as we cordoned off the scene
with that I'll take any additional
questions you may have is the victim of
someone who was willing to be working in
the house or someone who lived in the
house right now the information we have
is that the victim is related to the
owner of the house
and they were working on the house
that we do not believe that they lived
at the house
I believe they were shot by someone else
who was inside the house or someone
shooting into the house or outside
that's the part we're trying to
ascertain right now through our
interviews we're trying to gain a
clearer picture of what occurred who was
here likely when it happened and who
wasn't here likely when it happened
right now the all parties on the scene
English is a second language so we're
having to go through a little bit of a
language barrier as we ascertain those
facts we talked to quite a few neighbors
who were kind of concerned to hear about
this is this an isolated incident or do
you believe that you know there is a
threat still right now I would say based
information I have this is an isolated
incident it appears to be something
connected within this family that owns
the residents and who's doing work on
the residents